WE TALKED A LOT UP ON THE SHOW
ABOUT THE THREAT TO FREE SPEECH.
IT TURNS OUT IT'S VERY REAL.
LAST WEEK WE INTERVIEWED A MAN
NAMED HON ARO LOPEZ.
HE IS EXACTLY THE KIND OF PERSON
THAT YOU WOULD THINK A LOT OF
AMERICAN JOURNALISTS WOULD WANT
TO TALK TO.
FOR MONTHS, THEY HAVE DEMANDED
THAT THE MIGRANT CARAVAN FROM
HONDURAS MUST BE ADMITTED INTO
THE UNITED STATES.
ONCE IT GETS HERE IT WILL BE
GREATLY IMPROVED BY ITS
PRESENCE.
THAT'S HOW IMMIGRATION WORKS.
IT TURNS OUT, THE ONE WE'VE BEEN
TELLING YOU ABOUT HAS BEEN
ENCAMPED IN TIJUANA FOR WEEKS.
SIMPLE QUESTION.
HAS A CARAVAN MADE TIJUANA
BETTER?
LOPEZ WOULD KNOW THE ANSWER, AS
HIS JOB IS TO REPRESENT THE
CITIZENS OF THAT CITY.
WE'VE INVITED HIM TWICE TO ASK
ABOUT THE CARAVAN AND HERE IS
SOME OF WHAT HE TOLD US.
>> IT SEEMS THAT SOMEBODY IS
CLEANING UP GARBAGE.
IS THERE A LOT OF TRASH THERE?
>> THERE IS A LOT OF TRASH.
IT GREW TO 6200, AND SO WE GOT
ANOTHER, IT'S A BIG CONCERT HAL
HALL.
>> THAT WAS ON DECEMBER 3RD.
TEN DAYS LATER, WE INVITED LOPEZ
BACK ONTO THE SHOW TO SEE HOW
TIJUANA WAS DOING.
NOBODY ELSE IN THE MEDIA SEEMED
INTERESTED, AND THAT COULDN'T
REALLY BE USED TO ATTACK
DONALD TRUMP.
AND HERE IS WHAT LOPEZ TOLD US.
>> THINGS AREN'T GETTING ANY
BETTER THERE.
THAT WEEKEND WE HAD AN ULTIMATUM
THAT ARE CAMPING OUT HERE ON THE
STREET, THAT ARE BLOCKING THE
STREET.
PROBLEMS ARE GOING ON AND THERE
HAS BEEN LIKE 280 ARRESTS.
BEFORE IT WAS ONLY FOR DRUG
POSSESSION AND BEING DRUNK IN
THE STREETS AND NOW IT'S
BREAKING AND ENTERING TWO HOMES.
>> TRASHING THE STREET, DOING
DRUGS IN PUBLIC, BREAKING INTO
HOMES.
THAT'S NOT AT ALL WHAT CNN
PROMISED US.
WAS THAT ONE OF OUR WHITE
NATIONALISTS THAT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WAS WARNING
US ABOUT?
AND MAYBE, AND THIS IS OUR
CONCLUSION, THERE COULD BE A
LESSON FOR THE UNITED STATES.
IT'S OBVIOUS THAT WE NEED MORE
SCIENTISTS AND SKILLED ENGINEER
ENGINEERS.
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT WE ARE
GETTING, INSTEAD WE ARE GETTING
WAVES OF PEOPLE WITH HIGH SCHOOL
EDUCATION OR LESS.
NICE PEOPLE, NO ONE DOUBTS THAT
BUT AS AN ECONOMIC MATTER, THIS
IS INSANE.
INSTEAD, OUR LEADERS DEMAND THAT
YOU SHUT UP AND ACCEPT THIS.
EVEN IF IT MAKES OUR OWN COUNTRY
POOR AND DIRTIER AND MORE
DIVIDED.
IN THE ECONOMY IT COULD BE
PREFERABLE TO IMPORT MORE
ENGINEERS AND FEWER PEOPLE WITH
THE LOWEST SKILLS.
THAT'S WHAT WE SAID, THAT WAS
OUR CLAIM.
NOBODY ON THE LEFT DATE ARGUE
WITH IT, THEY IGNORED IT.
INSTEAD THEY ZEROED IN ON THE
LAST LINE.
THE LEFT SAID WE HAVE A MORAL
OBLIGATION TO ADMIT THE WORLD'S
POOR.
THAT'S WHAT WE SAID.
THANKS TO THE EFFORTS OF THE
AMERICAN LEFT, THE IMMIGRATION
POLICY EXISTS FOR THE PROFIT AND
COMFORT OF A RELATIVELY TINY
NUMBER OF PEOPLE.
EVERYBODY ELSE GETS SHAFTED
INCLUDING HON ARO LOPEZ AND AN
AWFUL LOT OF PEOPLE JUST LIKE
HIM.
A LOT OF PEOPLE PROFITING FROM
THE DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO THINK
ABOUT IT TOO MUCH.
THOSE WHO WON'T SHUT UP GET
SILENCED.
YOU HAVE SEEN IT A MILLION
TIMES, IT HAPPENS ALL THE TIME.
THE ENFORCERS SCREAM, RACIST, ON
TWITTER, UNTIL EVERYONE GETS
INTIMIDATED AND CHANGES THE
DESCRIPTION.
IT WON'T WORK FOR THE SHOW, WE
ARE NOT INTIMIDATED.
WE PLAN TO SAY WHAT'S TRUE UNTIL
THE LAST DAY.
THE TRUTH IS, UNREGULATED MASS
IMMIGRATION HAS BADLY HURT THIS
COUNTRY'S NATURAL LANDSCAPE.
TAKE IT FOR THE SOUTHWESTERN
DESERTS IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE IT.
THANKS TO IMMIGRATION, HUGE
SWATHS OF THE REGION ARE COVERED
WITH GARBAGE AND WASTE.
AND EACH ILLEGAL BORDER CROSS OR
LEAVE 6-8 POUNDS OF TRASH DURING
THE JOURNEY INTO OUR COUNTRY.
IF YOU ARE INTERESTED IN MORE
DETAIL, LOOK AT THE WEBSITE
THEY'VE CREATED CALLED ARIZONA
BORDER TRASH DEDICATED TO
CLEANING UP THE THOUSANDS OF
TONS OF GARBAGE STREWN ACROSS BY
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
THE GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABILITY
OFFICE PUT IT THIS WAY.
"ILLEGAL BORDER ACTIVITY ON
FEDERAL LANDS NOT ONLY THREATENS
PEOPLE BUT ENDANGERED SPECIES
AND THE LAND ITSELF.
ILLEGAL ALIENS AND SMUGGLERS
HAVE DESTROYED CACTUS AND OTHER
SENSITIVE AS VEGETATION THAT CAN
TAKE DECADES TO RECOVER.
ONE LAND MANAGEMENT OFFICIAL
DESCRIBED IN OTHER PROPERTY ON
ARIZONA'S BORDER AS SO UNSAFE
WITH RESOURCES SO DESTROYED THAT
IT IS PRIMARILY USED FOR ILLEGAL
ACTIVITY AND NO LONGER VISITED
BY THE GENERAL PUBLIC.
IT'S NOT A PRESS RELEASE FROM
DONALD TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN TEAM,
IT'S A FEDERAL STUDY FROM 2002
WHICH WAS BACK WHEN PEOPLE COULD
DO SCIENCE WITHOUT GETTING FIRED
FOR IT.
THE LAND, THE WATER, THE
ANIMALS, THEY UNDERSTAND THAT
AMERICA IS BEAUTIFUL BECAUSE
IT'S OPEN AND UNCROWDED.
NOT SO LONG AGO,
ENVIRONMENTALISTS OPPOSED TO
MASS IMMIGRATION AND THEY KNEW
WHAT THE COSTS WERE.
THEY STILL KNOW, BUT THEY DON'T